lucifer why don't you like me this dog
is beautiful oh no
what are you doing
[Music]
hi my name is ciel and today i'm going
to be picking a date based on their pets
i
currently have a cocker spaniel and i
absolutely adore him but i've always
loved pets i had two snakes they were
really cute they were kenyan sand boas
i've never dated anyone ever this is
probably an odd start
to dating i think my type is the type of
person who is kind enough to share their
life with a furry or scaly animal i'm
very single i'm a pringle so
i think this will be really fun
hey i'm quincy and this is my cat
lucifer say hello this is her lucifer
really doesn't match my aesthetic at all
like he's like the little dark cloud in
my otherwise like pastel like girly life
despite him being like a little bit of a
devil he actually is quite the snuggle
bug and he will sleep on top of you
every single night i've definitely dated
people who have been indifferent towards
lucifer it's a huge turn off and it
honestly makes me sad lucifer listen i
need you to go in there first impression
matters okay
hi i'm jalen and this is my buddy shadow
shadow is like my best friend he's made
me so happy everybody typically loves
shadow he goes with me everywhere so
he's literally my little shadow he's
full of energy he's very sweet he's very
loving and he's very energetic just like
his daddy i trust that the right person
will find me because of him all right
shadow just do what you do okay my name
is roy and this is jessica she looks
like she's gonna be like scary but she's
not you know she's very lovable people
just assume huskies are like kind of
dumb but then once you like get to know
them more it's like
this dog is pretty smart the
bachelorette might be like scared of her
but then once she kind of sees how
playful she is i think she'll nudge her
i've got this you are kind you are smart
and you don't smell that bad i'm ready
to meet some pets
oh it's a kitty oh well love this
carrier this is very cool i love me some
pokemon good she likes pokemon that's a
win hi i'm lucifer oh you've got an
intense name i'm not the best with first
impressions and i get a bit anxious in
new environments but if you give me
treats you'll have my heart well
you're in luck she went for the trees
good move good move feisty on the
outside snuggle bug on the inside i'll
be by your side day and night but touch
is not my love language me neither i'm
gonna let him out we'll see what happens
hello
he looks so scared
wait look
you see this
you don't know
this is not a good sign you don't like
me since he doesn't want to be with me
like i want to win his affection he
definitely plays hard to get i think the
owner is maybe female they seem like a
like a calm person i mean she got that
right for sure she got a nice chunky
belly i like that he is quite the chunk
and this is him on a diet too so i could
see myself having fun with him i really
want him to like me so i'm excited maybe
to meet his owner later oh hello
hi i love your keys she loves your keys
you're very cute and small where are you
going
not me being animal repellent and you
have a bow you got your outfit on yeah i
knew the ball would do it she likes the
bow hi i'm shadow i'm very friendly
could have fooled me shadow and i love
meeting new people i'm also very
energetic and playful and i love
spending time exploring outdoors
sometimes i'm a feisty firecracker other
times i'm sweet like a teddy bear and i
love to curl up on your lap or follow
you wherever you go like your shadow get
ready for some kisses i have not
received one kiss from you shadow
usually animals love me what is your
problem
i think he's definitely spooked by
something and just kind of nervous about
the environment you kind of feel like an
older person's dog i'm not too old but
um i've been told i have a pretty old
spirit i think shadow's so cute but i
feel offended because shadow hasn't
kissed me once oh and now you're leaving
me oh no no no boo-boos
shadow how could you go boo-boos i don't
want to smell that probably not a good
look
oh it smells
if i pick your parent we're going to
have to work on our relationship okay
because i want kisses bye shadows nice
to meet you
even though you pooped
oh my god you're so pretty oh hello win
some treats oh that's yummy you've got a
lot of energy friends the bachelorette
seems a little scared of jessica this
dog is gorgeous i've always wanted a
husky i
love them so much and this one is so
beautiful beautiful color beautiful eyes
i like the scarf again some style
she's way too distracted so let's learn
a little bit more about you friends
hello my name is jessica i'm a pretty
cool dog that loves to chill i am five
years old and loves skateboarding with
my owner you skateboard you're cooler
than me we'll do trick for treats amber
is the color of my energy like my coat
let's see what kind of tricks you can do
oh she's peeing oh
it's embarrassing okay let's do some
tricks okay sit
oh
wow
sit
okay
oh good oh you're so good
they're getting along pretty nicely i'm
impressed first of all the fact that you
can do tricks is awesome oh do you want
belly rub
do you want belly rub
oh i can do belly brush jessica really
loves belly rubs i think we're best
friends now i think jessica likes me the
fact that you can do tricks and that
you're so beautifully groomed and you're
so cool means that you have a very
dedicated owner and you guys probably
have a great relationship and i'm
jealous overall she really did try to
get along with her so i like that okay
yes i think our time is up but maybe
i'll meet you again later
get out of here
bye jessica so i met three animals today
the first animal lucifer the little
black kitty to be honest i really liked
him despite the fact that he did not
give a [ __ ] about me at least she liked
him okay like that's a win the second
animal i met was shadow the little
yorkie who decided to put all of his
business all over
the scene in front of me did not love
that but he was very cute good synopsis
of shadow sounds pretty promising the
third animal jessica the big beautiful
husky with all that energy so gorgeous
honestly i was enamored by her from the
moment she walked in it's really between
lucifer and jessica oh we're in the
final two the fact that he has a chance
i'm like wow
it's gonna be yesterday i think that the
dedication to spend you know so much
time and effort on your furry friend i
think that that's
very attractive of their owner so that's
why that's why i choose yes oh actually
want something
dope hi
nice to meet
you mcl you have a great dog thank you
thank you yeah she's cool you guys
skateboard and stuff we do so i have two
huskies actually and then we both go
like on my longboard and they pull so do
you want to go on a date oh for sure i'm
done cool yeah so we are here drinking
juice and coffee coffee
talking about homelessness in l.a
yeah
and gentrification
we don't stand in creation we don't
stand gentrification and we're just
vibing we actually i feel like we're
having a very la conversation exactly
with coffee and plants yeah with coffee
and plants
[Music]
you